well I didn't have Salma Hayek sitting
at a wedding on my Black Mirror bingo
card that's right season 6 of Black
Mirror is off to an explosive start with
a truly unique story that will have you
saying uh Selma Hayek's heinous okay
maybe not that but you can probably
guess the type of humor you'll be
getting in this video I'm sorry
that I shot in a church so join me as we
take a deep dive into Joan is awful all
the Black Mirror Easter eggs and
emmy-worthy dialogue then I hope that
you get paper cuts in your cameras and
die the episode starts with a Netflix
style logo for streamberry a
multi-million dollar streaming platform
with the goal of creating tailored AI
content for all 800 million of its
subscribers and it uses a powerful
quantum computer but I'm getting ahead
of myself meet Joan Tate our story's
protagonist her life's about as vanilla
as a Mormon Sunday but as we'll soon
learn her seemingly perfect life isn't
what it's cracked up to be she wants
more from her relationship her job has
her doing the dirty work for a soulless
board of directors and overall she feels
that she has no control over her life I
feel like I'm not the main character in
my own life story even Sandy the
co-worker she lets go calls her a coward
you're a coward Joe but things are about
to change when she and her boyfriend
Chris sit down to enjoy some amazing
stream Berry content and find a show
called Joan is awful but if you look
closely you'll see all the other
stringberry programs are Easter eggs
from previous Black Mirror episodes
there are a ton here so white bear with
me first is mad mind a documentary on
Jerome F Davies the author of which
bandersnatch is based on a film called
smart based off Michael smart a
politician in Demon 79 then of course
there's space Fleet from season 4's USS
Callister and what about average people
this is the only one I wasn't able to
crack but could be a reference to the
fact an average person was deliberately
chosen as the inspiration for Joan is
awful there's Locke Henry the next
episode in season 6 and perhaps the
biggest Easter egg in black mirror Sea
of Tranquility which is referenced in
four other episodes in national anthem
the special effects expert hired to fake
the prime minister's shagging a pig says
he worked on it and in nosedive there
are a few characters who chat about
attending Tranquility con then their
Smithereens were hashtag Sea of
Tranquility reboot is trending and
finally in Rachel Jack and Ashley 2
where a reporter talks about it getting
a reboot next up is finding Rittman from
black mirror's bandersnatch Hotshot the
virtual talent show whose winners can
live a life of luxury from season 1's 15
million merits Rowdy and peanut an
animated Show on Netflix from the
creators of Black Mirror that Kalo years
a documentary on Michael callow who had
sex with her Pig fancy dogs last day
which features an image of a Yorkshire
Terrier I think this is a nod to San
Junipero since its main character is
named Yorkie and she too is experiencing
her last days now we only get to see the
top half of the next set of stringberry
Originals there's season 2's white bear
on the bottom from left and this isn't
the only white bear reference the law
firm Joan goes to is called Skilling
legal named after the main character
from White Bear Victoria scalane then
there's bother guts one of the show's
Daniel kaluya's character watches while
peddling for points in season one's 15
million merits to the right we can make
out on a roll a reference to Ashley O's
hit single from season 5's Rachel Jack
and Ashley too and of course Junipero
dreaming a reference to San Junipero one
of my personal favorites in the entire
Anthology it doesn't take long for Joan
to realize that Joan is awful is an
exact play-by-play of her life with
actress Salma Hayek playing the titular
role and the show doesn't pull any
punches in depicting her in the most
awful light possible firing Sandy
without a care purposely dropping an
e-cigarette on her and making the first
move cheating on her fiancee but as
we'll find out later there's a
particular reason for this change fun
fact while Sandy is notified about the
show on her phone you can see see a
message from The Smithereens app the
Uber style Rideshare company seen in
season 5. now this show completely
dismantles Jones life she loses her job
fiance and can't even get laid because
her ex is now having performance anxiety
she could really use some inspiring
posts from season 3's Lacey pound and
while I'm here another reference to PM
Michael smart from demon79 and if you
look really closely you'll see this
message from Tusk the kid which says you
can't cancel me this is a reference to a
literal two-second blurb in Rachel Jack
and Ashley 2 where he apparently made a
big mistake on a British reality show
before we get any further please take a
moment to like And subscribe I'll be
covering every episode this season and
every little bit helps Joan tries to
take legal action but finds that by
signing up with stringberry she's given
them the rights to do anything they want
with her likeness in fact Joan is awful
is completely written and produced by a
quantum computer with President Mona
javadi stating that this is the future
by taking the likeness of celebrities
they can have the computer come up with
stories that are tailor-made for each
individual user and negative content
tends to elicit more of a reaction and
thus engagement hence why Joan is so
awful we'll also see a newspaper article
with Mona on the front page but if you
look off to the side you'll see an
article stating grains going out of
style this is a reference to the memory
grains which record all memories found
in season ones the entire history of you
but while Joan is pissed that her life
is destroyed so too is Salma Hayek's
that's not the real Salma Hayek playing
the role of Joan rather a CGI version of
her after she lent her likeness to
streamberry and stream Berry has her by
the balls they can do anything as per
her contract so in an act of desperation
Joan shits herself in the middle of a
wedding and Salma Hayek's character who
plays her has to do the same thing thus
sullying Her Image I mean doesn't my
have any rhyme okay this is what
causes Joan and Selma to join forces
their lives have been ruined so why not
break into streamberry and destroy the
thing that's caused them so much pain
but what they find is about to shake the
very foundations of their existence the
entire operation seems to be run by one
man Michael Sarah yes the actual Michael
Sarah who like Salma Hayek loaned his
likeness to stringberry as well but when
Joan looks at the screen to see the
episode generating she realizes her
character doesn't look like her at all
that's because Joan isn't the real Joan
she's actress Annie Murphy of shit's
creek Fame who is merely playing Joan
and what Michael calls fictive level one
the Jones she's seeing on screen is the
real Joan who he calls Source Joan an
ordinary average woman of no particular
interest who's being used as a test
study for this whole operation what we
have here is essentially a show within a
show within a show that goes on
indefinitely it's starts in the real
world with Source Joan and then actress
Annie Murphy playing her then in actress
Annie Murphy's show Salma Hayek plays
her this is what Michael Sayer would
call fictive level one an infective
level 2 I.E Salma Hayek's show Kate
Blanchett Placer and on and on so when
Joan has the ability to destroy the
quantum computer she has a choice leave
it be and go on with her life or destroy
it and kill the billions of simulated
Souls including herself that would go
along with it but she soon realizes this
isn't her choice to make she's merely
following the footsteps of what her
Source did the real Joan so it's the
real Joan who decides to smash the
computer and free herself finally taking
control of her life and making her own
decisions a complete turnaround for what
she told her therapist at the beginning
of the episode I just feel like I never
actively
chose this
like I feel like I'm just on autopilot
the real Joan is escorted out of stream
Berry after successfully destroying the
computer with a quick glimpse of Annie
Murphy in the same outfit that Salma
Hayek wore when she played her part in
fictive level 1. but what this journey
has done for Joan is completely change
her life she stopped seeing Mac who is
toxic for her and Chris who wasn't the
one for her she's let go of her
corporate job and is now her own boss at
her dream job of running a coffee shop
for the first time she feels like she's
the main character of her own life even
Andy Murphy comes to visit her with both
of them wearing matching ankle monitors
so they don't go around breaking any
more of those quantum computers and if
you stick around for the after credit
scene you're treated to the absolutely
heartwarming footage of source Jones
her pants in the real world
speaking of the real world of Black
Mirror episodes often shine a light on
things that are happening here it's only
a matter of time before AI machines like
streamberry write animate and produce
their own shows without the need of
writers actors and crew true I mean
there are already completely animated
shows being made by AI right now like
this Seinfeld inspired one that airs on
Twitch but something tells me we have a
bit more time before we get to Jonah's
awful quality levels it's also a bit
ironic that Netflix aired a show about
the dangers of AI writing when it's
currently fighting the writer's Guild
over AI writing I really hope you
enjoyed this video I plan on covering
each episode this season so consider
liking and subscribing but now I want to
hear what you thought about the episode
in the comments below thanks for
watching for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstoryyt until next time remember
hey how are you doing out there cool
foreign